[Music]
you're traveling
deep beneath the ocean's surface where
faint lights flicker
and toothy grins flash you are now
entering
the twilight zone your mission is to
survive these depths and
journey to the surface after sundown to
feed
you may now pick your player just
kidding
you don't have a choice you're a hatchet
fish
and almost everything else is trying to
eat you
the tools at your disposal are a
uniquely shaped body
shiny scales and glowing spots on your
belly
you're going to need a lot of skill and
a little luck
your first challenge is to begin your
upwards trek
your swim bladder allows you to
precisely control your buoyancy
come nightfall you slowly fill it up
becoming less dense
and rising towards the surface you can't
swim
fast but your narrow build makes you
maneuverable
this is especially important since
predators could spring out of the
darkness
at any moment in fact a fang tooth is
gliding beneath you
it has the ocean's biggest tooth to body
size ratio
food is hard to come by in the twilight
zone so predators have fearsome
adaptations
to make every attack count the fangtooth
skin
is ultra black it reflects less than 0.5
percent
of the light that hits it making this
fish particularly hard to spot
fortunately the bioluminescent organs
lining your belly
are regulated to match the intensity and
pattern of the faint light from the
ocean's surface
this counter illumination disguises your
silhouette
so when the fangtooth gazes upwards
you're almost invisible
a bright spot appears in the distance
you go to check it out
but something's looming in the darkness
the light is a bioluminescent lure
belonging to an angler fish you dart
away before it quickly opens its jaws
sucking in a hapless fish that got too
close
another narrow escape but you're nearly
there
although more than 90 percent of deep
sea creatures are bioluminescent
only one group produces the color red
dragon fishes
one of them is near because red light is
quickly absorbed by sea water
most deep sea inhabitants can't see it
the dragonfish emits red light from
organs by its eyes
using an invisible headlight to locate
unsuspecting prey
that it scoops into its cavernous jaw
you can't see your enemy
but your silvery mirror-like scales
scatter and soften
direct light keeping you hidden after
three close calls
you reach the photic zone you've just
participated in the world's largest
migration
it takes place every night as trillions
of organisms rise from the ocean's
depths
to enjoy the surface's rich resources
under the cover of darkness
the payoff is huge here your
light-sensitive eyes take in a buffet of
small crustaceans
and gelatinous zooplankton during the
day
phytoplankton used sunlight to turn
dissolved carbon dioxide
into energy and build their own cells
they become
food for small grazers forming the base
of the food web
which extends back down to the twilight
zone and beyond
organic matter generated up here like
bits of skin
poop and dead animals eventually sinks
or is transported in the stomachs of
animals returning from their nightly
migrations
these materials then feed the creatures
below that don't migrate
this ensures that some of the carbon
from the atmosphere
is locked away in the ocean for hundreds
of years to come
that's why this process is known as the
biological carbon pump
without it there'd be much more carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere where it
contributes to climate change
your avatar the hatchet fish is part of
this crucial process
your first quest is complete but you
must repeat this journey
every night for the rest of your life
as the sun rises the surface becomes
dangerous
and you descend back into the shadows of
the twilight zone
well done on this round but could you
survive as a newborn
sea turtle only 50 of them make it from
the sand
to the surf and even fewer live to
adulthood
join a group of hatchlings as they face
predators and fight for survival
with this video